I think it's gonna be hard.
I think audiences will identify me with that character for a long, long time.
I just gotta go try and convince directors that I can play other roles, be interesting.
Does it worry you slightly?
It would be very naive of me not to be aware that, that might be an issue,...
...but it's not impossible.
My job is to convince them otherwise.
I think there's some confusion.
I think the media don't really understand my decision to go to a university.
I think they think that's a bit odd.
So, they are sort of saying that...
...it means I'm giving up acting, which doesn't at all.
It means, I'm just taking a bit of a break for a couple of years and,...
... you know, I've managed to juggle my film career alongside my school...
...up until this point. So, I just sort of expect that to continue and...
No, I think they got a bit carried away.